well ever since the Las Vegas Review
journal's investigative reporter Jeff
gearman was stabbed to death lawyers for
the RJ and Metro have been fighting in
court Metro took gearman's phones and
computers the night of the murder but
the RJ claims the phones and the
information on them belonged to them a
news now investigator Kyle Payne was in
court for a tense hearing today and
joins us now live in studio
Metro on the yard
of Arts constitutional court cases are
concerned but the murder defendant
Robert Tellis is also in the mix Telus
representing himself and today it looked
to me like he and the review journal
have taken sides against Metro
I'm just circulating
order and give the parties an
opportunity to make any objection
objections abound in this case we didn't
take anything from the RJ but the RJ
says Metro took airman's devices and all
his confidential sources Metro says it's
none of their business they're
intervening in this matter when they
have standing to do so the standing
according to the RJ comes from the
Constitution and the newspaper's lawyers
say their right to those phones and the
info on them is absolute we didn't even
need to file all of this
all this is all these motions back and
forth between Metro the newspaper and
Telus until Telus in the review journal
agreed on a proposal for who should be
able to look at what's on the phones the
review journal parties and Mr Telus
jointly submitted a request after that
request we captured this footage of
Telus and the RJ lawyers huddling up
after court but that didn't stop tell us
from arguing with the judge who he'd
previously tried to get removed from the
case
so this argument's been going on pretty
much since the night gearman was killed
all three sides tell us the RJ Metro
have sent in written motions proposals
briefs you name it and we keep inching
closer to some sort of resolution
resolution but right now we're waiting
on the judge
Kyle why is this essentially going on so
long and why is it getting so ugly well
it started off so ugly and hasn't really
gotten any better mostly because the RJ
has said Metro wasn't forthcoming about
whether they reviewed the phones it
turns out they did to some degree and
it's taking so long pretty much because
the judge's rulings aren't necessarily
final so she says I think I would rule
this way or that and then if the paper
Metro tell us doesn't like it they can
bring it to the Nevada Supreme Court and
that takes time so all this is sort of a
distraction but what about act the
actual murder trial well the murder
trial has definitely been delayed and is
this is delaying the trial Metro says
they need the phone for their
investigation the newspaper is willing
to willing to concede that point but
doesn't want them to see all of garmin's
sources
Kyle thanks for that